well in check you you had gone to UCLA
film school right and yes finished in
the early 60s made some shorts but this
was your first feature right so yes so
now how on earth did you arrive at this
story and and also at the I mean the
resources to be able to make it and
everything yeah well just to make that
story very very short it was the Carl
Schanzer the actor who played mr.
Sherlock he was a private detective at
the time as well as he had been an actor
in New York on Broadway and but he was
working under the undercover Private Eye
checker and the he was doing some work
for these two producers who had been
actually at UCLA in the in the theater
department same time I had been there
although I had never met them and they
were in the real estate development of
business and they wanted to get into the
film business and they were looking for
a low-budget horror project to get
started with which is the way a lot of
people used to get started and so he
told him he knew this fellow who had a
story and he showed them the story they
had been reading lots and lots of
scripts when they read this story even
though it was not in script for him they
thought they just went well this is not
like anything else they had read so they
were foolish enough or wise enough
depending on how you look at it to go
for it and they hired me to write the
script which I wrote I think in about
ten days today it takes me two years to
write a script and we set it up and shot
it on a budget of $50,000 since we're in
the home of the Oscars here sort of in a
way so to speak very early on in the
shoot and Carole hallmark everybody was
so pleased with with this wonderful
script as they thought they're all
having so much fun Carole mark came here
she's very serious she said do you think
we could qualify for an Oscar with this
picture it was at that point I knew I
had perfectly cast that character